[Musique]
enlevez vos chaussures et préparez vous
à vivre une expérience éducative
original bienvenue à la croisée des
chemins
ici pas de classe aucun prof et aucun
élève et pourtant nous sommes bien dans
une école dans les écoles classiques ne
digère sont chers ça et mon travail
alors que les en avertir
pour un promu comme on veut l'école
démocratique de dijon hors contrat avec
l'état a ouvert ses portes il ya trois
ans ici ce que l'on appelle les
facilitateurs accompagne 20 enfants âgés
de 3 à 16 ans tout le monde cohabite
dans le même espace et chacun fait ce
qui lui plaît quand ça lui plaît passé
sa journée sur l'ordinateur faire du
trampoline ou faire du français en
écrivant une carte à sa maman ça c'est
maman parce que m
comme une maman humains ont fait part à
mme toussaint à
on fait la même chose que dans les
écoles classiques mais avec plus de
liberté par exemple alors moi
aujourd'hui je veux faire le max mais
pas sous forme de l'exercice de maths je
veux faire des maths par exemple
en comptant tous les tous les cas plat
que je mette sur une tour une très très
grande tour voilà la liberté comme
pédagogie le concept peut laisser un peu
perplexe fleurs la directrice l'avouent
elle aussi lui a fallu du temps pour
vaincre ses propres réticences
aujourd'hui elle est convaincue selon je
me suis rendu compte c'est qu'on peut
leur faire confiance
et c'est même la seule chose qu'on peut
faire finalement d'en faire confiance et
de la même manière qu'ils ont appris à
marcher et à parler
et bien voilà ils sont prêts à prendre à
compte et à lire a semblé laisser
l'assemblée a semblé au centre de la vie
de cette école le débat démocratique
donc première proposition courir dans
l'école la façon dont on avait écrit la
proposition s'était pas de dire qu'il
était interdit de courir en général mais
que le jeu de course poursuite n'est pas
autorisé toutes les règles du vivre
ensemble sont prises ensemble à la
majorité absolue la voix des petits
compte autant que celle des adultes
est ce que quelqu'un a une objection
donc la proposition passe ça me paraît
évident qu on rêve à plus respecter une
règle quand on la comprend
et quand on a confiance en fait dans
l'environnement qui a créé cette règle
une école qui apprendrait à devenir
adulte et à mieux vivre ensemble
du haut de ses 14 ans abdou semble un
peu désoeuvrés mais fondamentalement
optimiste pour moi c'est plus une école
pour apprendre à savoir ce que tu veux
faire toi à te connaître et être capable
de
nos commerces à de parler avec les
autres de les respecter car à ces écoles
démocratique se développe en france à
une vitesse étonnante si elle ne
bénéficie d'aucune aide de l'état
elles sont tenus de transmettre le socle
commun de connaissances et peuvent être
inspectés à tout moment ticket d'entrée
à partir de 2700 euros
efficacité de la méthode trop tôt pour
le dire mais les enfants sont unanimes
aucun ne souhaite retourner dans le
système scolaire classique
[Musique]